[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now we had
some earlier technical difficulties but
there was no way we were going to miss
this segment it is chilly inside and
there's no better place to be but cozy
at home with cheese and here to give us
her favorites for the winter months is
diana breyer the wonder woman of cheese
welcome she's also the owner of valley
cheese and wine and we're talking about
cozy melty cheeses today tell us you've
got so you've got this little
contraption here what is this i do this
is actually called a mini raclette grill
so this is a contraption that has a
heating unit and a plate on top and the
heating unit also allows for you to have
little trays underneath
that allow you to be sort of melting
multiple things at one time for example
i've got cheese melting here in the
bottom and also grilling some halloumi
up top oh i i love it all right so
three cheeses and you've got three
different takes today what are some of
your favorite melty cheeses so a lot of
people have common misconceptions that
you have to melt the same cheeses all
the time and really there's such a huge
complexity of cheeses that can melt okay
that we're actually going to go through
a couple of like one classic grilling
cheese
one that's one of the most classic
melting cheeses and then we're gonna go
through a wild card that actually is
gonna make us
have a little bit of fun with our
palette i like when you do the wild
cards that's my favorite okay cheese
number one let's do it so cheese number
one is actually going to be um the
classic raclette so raclette is a noun
uh because it is the name of a cheese
and it also is a verb because it is what
you do to cheese or by way of melting
and scraping um so this is actually
we're taking raclette de montagna i
actually already did a little scrape
there so this is racletta montagna a raw
cow's milk cheese from france and we're
actually just gonna melt it and scrape
it all over right there but this is your
prepared bite right there so this is
actually genoa salami with a little bit
of roasted onion and garlic jam with
melted cheese in the center there's jam
in there there's yep onion and garlic
jam there
so this is gonna taste like the most
grown-up version of a lunchable you ever
did have my lunchables did not taste
like this this is amazing yeah you'd be
packing your lunch a lot more if they
did huh
you said this oh my gosh
with jam on salami okay um our next take
is actually going to be our sweet side
so if you want to grab one of these this
is actually an effie's oat cake these
are little dessert cakes and we actually
took a smoked goat's milk cheese from
the canary islands of spain put it into
the raclette grill and it's going to
actually serve as that like toasty
marshmallow component and then we melted
some ritual s'mores chocolate and
actually you're going to have a little
bit of like a s'mores essence this is
good it does look like s'mores here okay
this is cheese i gotta tell myself
cheese and dark chocolate and
accompaniments oh my goodness so that
smokiness is going to give you the
essence remind you of being around that
campfire while subbing out that
marshmallow component it pulls out that
chocolate taste and oh wow that is
amazing oh my goodness i don't know they
just keep getting better and better
every time and then the final cheese so
many of us are missing those classic
cheddar cheese curds but they really
don't taste the same unless they're
right out of the cheese making fat a lot
of people don't know about halloumi it's
a greek cheese you can grill it it gives
you that same squeak as a fresh cheese
curd has a lot of flavor and i actually
put it on a cured cheese chip so we went
next level today mercedes we did cheese
on cheese i mean it doesn't get any
better than that
you're so innovative with your flavors i
love it people want to check you out
where can they come see you i'm at
valley cheese and wine we are in
henderson on horizon ridge between
arroyo grande and
stephanie so really over in that
mcdonald ranch area but yeah valley
cheese and wine and you can find me
anytime wonder woman of cheese i'm
always here for your cheesy needs and
you can find me here eating all three